Seguramente sabes cómo se define la multiplicación de dos números, por ejemplo dos y tres; y lo hacemos a partir de la suma  ¿Okay?
Cuando tenemos dos enteros, como éstos, que se están multiplicando; lo que decimos es que dos por tres (2*3)es igual a sumar este dos, tres veces (2+2+2), ¿Okay?
Dos por tres (2*3)es igual a 2+2+2, ¿Okay? Estamos sumando al dos tres veces
Aquí está una vez, dos veces, tres veces, ¿Y qué es lo que nos queda? Pues 2+2 es cuatro, más dos (4+2) es seis
¿Okay? Entonces, dos por tres (2*3) es seis... ¿Y para qué hice yo todo esto de recordar cómo se define la multiplicación a partir de la suma?
Pues, porque vamos a definir a los exponentes... Tal vez suena un poquito exótico, pero con unos cuantos ejemplos vamos a ver que es súper sencillo; podemos empezar por ver por ejemplo
Dos elevado a la tercera potencia; este es el exponente (El numerito azul), y lo que esto significa es que vamos a tomar el dos y lo vamos a multiplicar tres veces
Vamos a poner por aquí dos por (Vamos a denotar el por por un puntito (*)) dos por dos (2*2*2), ¿Okay? Estamos tomando el dos y lo estamos multiplicando tres veces, y lo que nos queda es dos por dos; es cuatro (2*2=4), por dos, que es ocho (4*2=8)
Entonces dos elevado a la tercera potencia es igual a ocho (2 elevado a 3 = 8)
¿Muy bien? Yo digo que veamos otro ejemplo, ¿Okay? A ver, qué te parece si ahora vemos tres elevado a la segunda potencia
Pues eso es igual a tomar nuestro tres y multiplicarlo dos veces (3*3)
Entonces nos queda tres por tres; y eso es igual a nueve (3*3=9)
¿Okay? Entonces estuvo super fácil esto de encontrar tres elevado a la segunda potencia; entonces es simplemente tres por tres (3*3)
Ya a esto también le llamamos tres al cuadrado (3 elevado a dos); y a esto a veces también le llamamos dos al cubo (2 elevado a tres), pero sigamos con esto de los ejemplos
Y ahora, pues yo digo que hagamos algo un poquito más complicado
Como, por ejemplo, tomar cinco y elevarlo a la cuarta potencia
Ahorita, te recomiendo que le pongas una pausa al video y trates de averiguar por tus medios cuánto vale cinco elevado a la cuarta potencia
Y, cuando termines, le puedes poner Play y ver la respuesta
¿Okay? Eso es igual a tomar cuatro cincos y multiplicarlos (5*5*5*5)
Y a ver a cuánto será igual cinco elevado a la cuarta potencia
Pues, cinco por cinco es veinticinco (5*5=25)
Y luego veinticinco por cinco es ciento veinticinco (25*5=125)
Y finalmente ciento veinticinco por cinco, no me vas a creer; pero puedes hacer las cuentas
Y eso es igual a seiscientos veinticinco (125*5=625)